ساجيبك طالب ولكن سريعا يعني تصديقا لما
جاء في مقدمه النشره الان التي قراتها نعم
هذه عمليات هدم مثلا تجري الان لمبنى مدمر
وايل للسقوط يعني تقوم هذه الاليات بهدمه
والان يعني منذ دقائق بدات فيه على ايه
حال نحن لا زلنا نجول في مناطق انطاكيا
وفي
المتواحه السكنيه المنكوبه والمدمره
عمليات الانقاذ مستمره طالب ولكن يعني
بشكل مختلف هذه الملابس العزل التي تظهر
من امامك هي التي بدات ترتديها فرق
الانقاذ مؤخرا لان خشيه الامراض والاوبئه
وانتشارها هنالك طبعا بدات تختفي عمليات
البحث عن الناجين بصراحه رغم ان طبعا انا
سمعت الخبر عن السيده وطفليها وهذا صحيح
ولكن بنسبه قليله جدا يعني تكون هنالك
عمليات بحث عن ناجين تحت الانقاذ ولكن
المشكله الاكبر اطالب الان ان العمليات
بدات يعني
تزداد بوتيره مختلفه وكما قلت لك بملابس
العزل للبحث عن تحت الالقاب عن الجثامين
ومثلا هذا المبنى الذي تشاهده يعني فيه
طبعا اسر لا تزال تحت الانقاض حتى هذه
اللحظه هذا الكيس الاسود الذي يظهر في
الشاشه لطفله عمرها 25 يوم اخرجت من تحت
انقاذ هذا المبنى وضعت هنا جاء من يعني
يتجمهرون والاسر الواقفه هنا منذ ايام
تعرفوا اليها
كانت هنالك صعوبه صوروها وارسلوها الى
اشخاص لعائلات سوريه وبالفعل في نهايه
الامر تعرفت اليها عائله وتبين انها تخص
عائله سوريه ولكن هنالك من لا يزال ينتظر
المزيد من الجثث والضحايا هذه طبعا
الاكياس السوداء ايضا طالب
هذه جثث ايضا خرجت لرجل وامراه كما يحدثني
شخص هنا خرجت من تحت الانقاض يتم التعرف
اليها بمجرد ان تخرض تخرج الجثه ياتي
الناس هنا من ينتظر ويتعرف على هذه الجثث
اسمح لي سريع